look good afternoon everyone
ladies and gentlemen let it let me say
just to start that it's a great
privilege and a great honor for me to be
conducting this conversation with mr.
Annan this afternoon I am personally
immensely grateful for the fact that you
have come to Copenhagen to talk about
the book and really talk about the
themes that are engaged in the book and
not they are really the big themes that
occupy the international community today
and those are some of these themes that
we're going to talk about this afternoon
what we're going to do is we're going to
conduct a conversation between mr. Allen
and myself and then we will take
questions from the audience where
hopefully we will be able to see you
which we can't really do right now we
have the book really is a account of the
sacred generals time is leader of the UN
but very much also a discussion of the
big themes whether its peacekeeping or
the Middle East or development or Africa
and we want to touch on some of those
themes in our conversation and in the
question answer session as well but why
don't we start with the beginning
perhaps and the first chapter of the
book is called African beginnings and
this is of course a story of a beginning
in Africa for the sacred general but
also a the evolution of the continent
over these last many years an
extraordinary evolution but perhaps you
could share with us a little bit about
your beginnings and the Africa that you
came from thank you very much a another
and i'm also very pleased to be here
this afternoon to talk about the book
and I think his perhaps Africa is a good
place to begin as most of you know i was
born in africa and spent my most
formative years there and it was there a
peaceful ghana the peaceful society we
had lots of laughter we had large family
units it was in sort of her immediate
family
of two three four people usually when
the Africans talk of a family it can be
quite large as large as a hundred or
more with cousins and friends and close
relatives so in my house grandmother's
house and my father's we always had
people to talk to to seek advice to
laugh with to joke with and so one was
never really alone he did things and of
course at a young age I went to boarding
school you saw you came to visit me yet
not when i was in borders no but a
little later and later visited you know
and i went bored in school and i grew up
at a time when the struggle for
independence was going on and as young
people we followed this discussion of
freedom democracy independent africa
very intensely and in fact we played
roles I was seeing us a leader of the
Opposition amongst my group and there
were others who play the role of a
leader of the governing party and we
followed the incredible political
intensity of the country and as you grew
up watching this and suddenly you
achieved independence which brought on
incredible changes of ganyan Prime
Minister ganyan head of the army ganyan
police commissioner and all along the
line you realize change was possible
even very radical change and this is
something that really marked me
throughout my life that I like to push
the envelope I like to challenge and you
may remember sometimes in New York when
I suggested we do something and some of
the advice I said it can't happened has
never been done I would always say test
it let's test it and you'll be surprised
what you
fine so I still at this age I still
Guarin testin and pushing the envelope
Africa of course in the meantime has
gone through a whole host of changes my
country came got us independence in
March 57 the same here malaysia got his
independence they got the independence
in august 1957 and on the 50th
anniversary of both countries i had a
good fortune or being asked to speak in
both countries at the independence
anniversary and i couldn't help compare
the situation of the two countries when
we achieved independence we were almost
at the same level of development the
same amount of national reserves at the
bank and yet the gdp of malaysia was 13
times higher than that of ghana and then
you asked yourself how do you explain
that and it boils down to question of
governance ghana went through a series
of military coup details whereas
malaysia had a stable government of
course my tia stayed for about 20 years
but it was table and they continued
developing and they also had a consensus
of the direction the nation should move
in with us were the political changes
since that consensus was in there each
time you had the new government they
started from a fresh you brush aside but
the previous government had done so you
did not have something to build on and
this really caused problems but I and we
had similar situations in other parts of
Africa but today we have better
governance we have artificial society
developing keeping the politicians
honest we have an educated young men and
women who have worked and studied abroad
in Europe and America who are going back
to make a difference and now determined
to have a better
life and to help develop the continent
today there are fewer civil wars on the
continent and they used to be we have
seen major investments in Africa we have
new investors the Chinese the Indians
and Brazilians Malaysians and
indonesians the Europeans and the
Americans will be in the traditional
partners have been a bit on the
sidelines in some ways one in Africa is
to look be careful of the Chinese but I
tell them that's not a way to do it
compete with the Chinese and not for the
Africans a better model and use the
knowledge and the experience you have of
Africa to put it to good use and and I
think they are beginning to do that and
I really think Africa is on on this way
the years of big men leading countries
are over and i would encourage a
investors to look at Africa very
critically is the next continent I think
this ties to one of the themes in the
book which is the question of trade and
aid and Denmark obviously is a major aid
donor historically but also today how do
you think for Denmark as a as a donor to
Africa how should it think about the
balance between eight and trade in
Lisbon is debate that aid is in fact a
deadening factor is destructive to the
kind of initiative what is the right
balance do you think to be struck I
think the first of all no country can
develop through development assistance
alone I think development assistance and
they should be used to build capacity
and to strengthen institutions most
governments most countries would want to
stand on their own they would much
rather trade themselves out of poverty
than rely on assistance and in fact I
had a study done when our Secretary
General through UNDP to look at how we
deliver assistance and in a sustainable
sort of way
and one of the study's indicator that it
might be more helpful to develop small
and large scale companies industries
that will employ local people and make
it sustainable and quite a few good
several governments are looking at this
approach now and I think it will bear a
bear fruit so one should look at
supports in the small and medium-sized
companies why should look at support and
perhaps Danish companies investing in
Africa given them some sort of
guarantees or insurance to encourage
them to do that and I'm happy to say
that several countries have spoken to
looking at this model okay that's we
have a lot of course Ghana and Denmark
I've had very long relationship some
happy some not so happy I was going to
leave that out for now but we all we all
we all share christiansburg it's like we
have one in a crowd too that's right we
have a number of big themes but I think
one thing that that would love to hear
your thoughts about which does really go
through every dimension of the book is
this idea of intervention I mean the
English US and British title of the book
is interventions and it's really a theme
that I think goes back to your entire
career at the UN but very much a sec
regional coming into the role and very
much having the view that you wanted to
see the UN in a more active in a more
intervening roll one that cared more one
was able to act more this is often seen
through the prism of conflicts and
military intervention but there's a
broader theme here that I think
characterizes your time and which we
talked about in the book no absolutely
right because what we should be about at
the end of the day it's improving the
condition of the individual the welfare
of the individual and that can be done
through containing conflict and Wars it
can be done by lifting them out of
poverty
it can be done by ensuring that they
have health facilities and you see it
when you travel around my wife nan is
here and we used to travel around and in
fact I used to be very jealous of her
program because we go to a country and I
go from the airport to the hotel to the
meeting to the airport and back again
and she goes to the villages visiting
women's programs and schools and others
and by and then we compare notes at the
end of at the end of the evening and I
wish I had hair program but in the
process you discover which we share the
pain and the agony of the people I
recovery when greater malo I'm Bolivia
we're a family came to see us with a
nine year old and the sir she has AIDS
we can't afford medication she's going
to die can't you help us so none
discussed it with me mr. why don't we
call the UNICEF representative to see if
they could help they managed to get her
medication but she died a year to later
we got the message she was an example of
millions around the world in that
situation and so what do you do we with
the UN launched the Global Fund to fight
hiv/aids malaria and tuberculosis
because the medication was there but the
poor couldn't afford it and when you
visit that hospitals and we when was
ambach we were twisted mother to child
thin hospital where they did a sketch
trying to convey the message of the
disease of their case and you knew that
there was medication that could save
this and they look at you in the eye
almost say can't you help me I know I
can be saved if i had money
so we when we set up the funder I
decided to go further and invited
chairman of the seven largest
pharmaceutical companies to a meeting in
Amsterdam to discuss we can make the
medication available to the poor and it
was a critical intervention because at
that time the medication costs 115 or
15,000 across 15,000 per person there is
no way the people in the third world
could afford this so I engage the
companies in sick could we reduce the
prices because if you are not able to do
it you're going to have problems you
cannot protect your intellectual
property you cannot as international
system to work with you and defending
your intellectual property when the
life-saving drug is available but the
poor allowed to die because they
couldn't afford it so we have to find a
way of doing it it was one of the most
interesting meetings I odd because the
first chairman to speak up said I don't
know why I'm here my lawyer is not here
and I said this is not a question of
lawyers he said no I could be accused of
fair price fixing I said price fixing
this sir when you collude with others to
increase your profits he I'm asking you
to lose money I'm asking you to I'm
asking you to cut back sir you're not
there another time by the way they were
seeing Mandela in the South African
court because he had threatened to use a
generic version of the medication to
treat his people so I advised him i said
look find a way of cutting the prizes
but don't i see this case with Mandela
in a South African court so I'm not a
public relations expert but if you go
and see Mandela in South Africa on an
issue of hiv/aids if you lose you lose
if you win you lose and lose and lose
so you better in the end they resolve it
out of the court but I give this to
indicate it was a massive contribution
from hundred and from 15,000 to 150
today we have millions people on the run
the medication that could not have
afforded it and we've also raised to 120
billion to help those living with the
disease we did the same in terms again
the individual on Millennium Development
Goals a fight against poverty coming up
certain basic requirements that we
should try and drive to ensure that
every individual asset were there's
primary education clean water the
norther and these goals were so simple
that the people understood that the
government's understood it and the
people could press their governments to
deliver and in places like Brazil China
India millions were lifted out of
poverty and even the smaller countries
have done quite a bit on clean water on
education on health and so we continue
and of course there is a military
aspects which people tend to focus on
which is not really there is a whole
essence of intervention but if we just
stay with that dimension will get to
another theme in a moment but very
important theme of your time was this
question of one is it right to intervene
and how should the international
community think of the rights and the
responsibilities of leaders towards
people living in their own countries and
this is something you started talking
about very early on in your psyche of
generalship which of course culminated
with the with the Kosovo conflict and
others and then ultimately with the idea
of a responsibility to protect how did
you see that evolution and and what did
you bring from your experience from head
of peacekeeping during the Rwanda
genocide the Bosnia wars that made you
prioritize that yeah actually those were
very difficult periods it was saying
twas a difficult period for the UN and
the international community but it was
also a personal journey for me a
personal journey in the sense that I
lived through the crisis in Somalia I
said in the peacekeeping department
where millions were starving we managed
to get in food but couldn't get her to
the needy because a group affair i once
called them radicals really criminals
were preventing the food from moving
from the warehouse to those who needed
it so President Bush Senior decided on
the advice of the Council on request of
secretary-general boutros-ghali to send
in US troops to ensure food go to the
needy so thousands of years he warned
about 91 92 Via thousands of US troops
went in it was then transformed into UN
peacekeeping operation and we had an
incident the u.s. plane was shot down
they were going after one of the
Warlord's and the bodies of the troops
were dragged through this capital city
of Somalia Mogadishu so the u.s. decided
to withdraw and almost all the Western
countries we drew with the best equipped
troops in the end the operation
collapsed and we left Somalia and the
international community forgot Somalia
for about 20 years until it came back to
bite us we dismissed it as a failed
state and they came back to bite us as a
center of piracy and suddenly Somalia
was on the map again and everybody was
talking of Somalia then Rwanda followed
where 800,000 people died with a small
UN force on the ground and we couldn't
do much at the same time we were
intrigued oh savia and similar
experience particularly with sabrina
we're a thousand young men were marched
out and killed so as an individual going
through this heart-wrenching and painful
experience you kept wondering what can
we do what do we do if we have another
Rwanda how do we react could we have
done more and in fact it was that
challenge that I plays before the
General Assembly in 1999 speech asked in
them what do we do if tomorrow we are
confronted with another Rwanda and that
was the genesis of this responsibility
to protect that led to a commissioned by
the Canadians to look into this whole
question of humanitarian intervention
when the report came out we distributed
liberally but I decided to wait until
the time in his right to pose the issue
of protection and that moment didn't
come till 2005 of the summit where I
recommended that the Member States
should accept that no country that
governments that each individual
government has a responsibility to
protect his own people from genocide
from crimes against humanity systematic
and gross abuses of human rights and if
that government is either unable
unwilling to do it then the
international community in the form of
security council can intervene to assist
the victims the implication of that norm
is that governments as of that date in
2005 could no longer hide behind
sovereignty and brutalize the Aaron
people and that those of us outside that
country do you also do not have an
excuse not to act we cannot say we don't
intervene in internal affairs that some
crimes are so shameful so unacceptable
that we have to act and that is how we
came by this question of a
responsibility to protect most people
tend to think it implies military action
but no military action can be resorted
to us a last resort I think one of the
best intervention on that basis was the
one in Kenya in five years ago when
after the elections and the parties got
into a conflict where in the relatively
short time 1300 people were killed
650,000 were uprooted I and two other
members panel members grasa Michelle the
wife of Nelson Mandela and president
bending kappa former president of
tanzania we're asked to go in to help
and the international community worked
with us very very effectively the
African Union the you and European Union
us everybody was there and we applied
also some diplomatic and political
pressure to end the killing and to get
them to accept a settlement and a
program of reform which led to a new
constitution two years ago and five
years on they've had elections without
violence with contentious results but
still without violence the case is in
court and I think that's a vindication
of this r2p let me turn to a theme that
I think lots of people's minds today
because it is the 10th anniversary of
the invasion of Iraq I don't think it's
something that's celebrated but it's
something that's marked and I think
they're there are lots of questions
around this this was very much a
crucible of your own leadership of the
UN
and for the institution of course the
entire period of the run-up was a very
difficult one the follow on from the
invasion and really certainly the most
difficult time of your sacral
generalship the killing of 22 of our
colleagues in baghdad in august of two
thousand three including Sergio Vieira
de Mello maybe before we talk about may
perhaps the lessons of this war for
today give a sense of your personal
experience of that period in that time
what did it impact it have on you the
difficulty the fade to face the UN what
it meant to our own people who were
there how do you recall that experience
today it is interested in there to go
back the the whole question of Iraq war
started as a slow-moving sort of train
and then it accelerated I think one has
to go back to 911 when the buildings
they look great the towers were brought
down the shock the anger and on that day
and the weeks thereafter the whole world
were with the US the u.s. got lots of
support and handled differently the
support and friendship will probably
still be around not soon after that I
remember muesli doing the peace and the
title was why do they hate us so much
and nice call the editor and I said
interest in peace but I would have put
on a different title what went wrong how
did we lose these friends around the
world what did we do and I think the
decision to declare war on terror to
lash out the fight in Afghanistan are
going after the Taliban was understood I
think most members in the UN supported
that but when it became
a broader war an impossible war on
terrorism worldwide even then the UN and
I myself came up with a plan where
members days could cooperate to contain
terrorists to deprive them of the
opportunities to ensure they are not
given haven they do not allow them to
use a financial system in order then
that transformed into attention on Iraq
first attempts were made to link Saddam
was in with the terrorists which was a
lie yea which was a lie then the
question of their arms cachet came up
that we need to go to Iraq to get rid of
the weapons by then the inspectors were
out then but we managed to get them back
in so dr. Blixen dr. ElBaradei were
doing their work and needed a bit more
time but president bush and the
coalition were in such a hurry that they
wouldn't give the inspectors time this
brought very serious divisions in the
organization hours at the center Colin
almost every leader from Latin America
to Africa to Asia to Europe and will
push and Tony Blair also in the end some
of us were hoping that they will not do
it because there we felt they needed a
resolution of the Security Council that
most people accepted that when the
country is attacked it had the right to
defend itself but when it came to a
question of broader security for all of
us you cannot do without the legitimacy
of the Security Council and I personally
was also concerned that if us can decide
to go and get rid of a government it
does
like for one reason or the what example
what president doesn't said could Russia
and allies do that could China and
allies to the a sort of a world are we
going to create when the quote and the
question I remember you asking the
coalition in the run-up and obviously
Denmark has had a very important role in
the in the operations both in Iraq and
Afghanistan it's been very much an issue
for this country but you were asking in
the weeks and months running up to the
war when it became clear that this was
very much a real possibility you would
ask them what happens when the bombing
stops exact right there's a lot of talk
now and it has been last ten years about
oh well we didn't expect that this could
unravel we didn't expect the insurgency
we didn't know this could happen would
you were asking him in before what
happens when the bombing stops and they
didn't have much of an answer let me it
brings one question because I know guy
do you think they were deceiving others
do you think they were deceiving
themselves particularly bush and Blair
and this was supposed to be a friendly
interview here know that that is the
question let me you know I have this
attitude about betrayal I said to betray
a friend you first have to go through
cell betrayal so to deceive all this you
have to also start by deceiving yourself
but you think you would win in the end
you think it wouldn't catch up with you
you think in the end everything will go
all right and I think some genuinely
believed that they will be received with
flowers and music and dancing most of us
oh I didn't know no country no people
want to welcome an occupier you may be
welcome for the first couple of weeks
soon you become an occupier and
everybody tends against you particularly
when they also question the legitimacy
and the basis
for the action but I think in Washington
definitely a group I decided it's time
to get rid of Saddam and we're looking
for excuses to go in and there was a
sense that during the first Iraq war in
night in 2001 they should have gone on
to Baghdad all the way but they I
attended an event in Kuwait the 20th
anniversary of that war and all the key
players were there Jim Bakker Colin
Powell another and discussing with Jim
Jim Baker said well Kofi this is a war
we fought right we stopped to the
Security Council resolution we did not
stray one inch we managed whether the
best and largest coalition of a and get
others to pay for it what else could you
want we're going to we're going to start
taking questions in a moment so those
are questions if you start thinking
about them i'm going to ask one more
which does come back to iraq in one way
but really to the question of what it
means to be the Secretary of the UN and
that is that you don't have the luxury
of choosing who to deal with and when
you came back from your first mission to
Baghdad in 98 you've been on a long
flight coming back you were exhausted I
think it's fair to say and a journalist
said to you after you'd had your meeting
with Saddam is Saddam someone you can do
business with and you said yes
essentially saying this is what I just
did I said that was held against you
then and has by some people ever since
as a way of saying that you were willing
to do business with mass murderers and
criminals what how do you manage that
balance and even personally when you're
sitting across the table from people who
have in some case has been responsible
for great crimes how do you justify that
to yourself and to the role first of all
I don't go and see these leaders to chit
chat and drink a scotch or have tea or
have tea with them I go with very
specific objective often it is to save
lives often is to improve hopeless
tuition when there's a conflict and you
want to make a difference I mean often
we talk of peace and justice the first
you needed is to stop the killing is to
try and attain some stability and then
the Justice I can follow I agree you
need justice but the first effort anew
you have to speak to those who can make
a difference in stopping the killing you
have to let the people responsible for
often this is the people responsible for
that and even before I go to this stage
you would recall I was very keen on the
establishment of the International
Criminal Court because we had a legal
system where if a man or a woman killed
one person they were likely to be
brought to court to be brought to trial
and held accountable but if they kill
thousands they got away scot-free
because often they were political
leaders or big generals that nobody went
after so you were putting into place
pegs and limitations and when you go and
speak to these people they ask you first
of all they also are waiting for you
they sometimes almost invariably try to
put their best foot forward to show you
they don't have horns they are human
which you know they are not because they
couldn't have done other things they've
done but you engage them and try to
reach them and look for a an opening
where you can get them to pull back or
shift and do what what is right
incredibly some seem so meek and gentle
and friendly laughing as if they haven't
done any of the things that they do for
example you meet them and probably meet
them in person I mean in that
conversation with Saddam Hussein he was
very calm very soft-spoken he wasn't
using the arms the way they do in the
region and even halfway through the
conversation he said
secretary-general would you excuse me I
have to go and pray so he left to pray
on that I said to myself well if he is
still praying then there's the hope and
after he had left to pray I tend to his
a the interpreter because the only three
of us in the room am I getting through
to him said yes yes yes because he
didn't want to be bothered I'll going
yeah he didn't want to be bombed either
any case we managed to delay the bomb
from februari till end of the year but
at that time it did come but it was a
good to do tour Assad who will sit and
tell you straight that yeah I have the
support of my people I wouldn't be here
after a year of conflict if they did not
support me or what you are watching on
television is virtual reality and let me
tell you was serious about and really
had sittin there discussing it with a
straight face and ostensibly believe in
what he was saying and also convinced
that he's going to prevail and trying to
push him to negotiate to talk to Joey we
might get a chance to come through the
questions you know so we have a little
time for questions if you would raise
your hand and I will be blunt enough to
say they are they've got please do ask a
question and not make a statement so
with that warning why don't we take a
question in the very back I think corner
hi my
hi my name is cavia come from Greenland
I'm wondering if the United Nation could
improve their financial structure
somehow some claim that the ladder
larger states and corporations have too
much power so um yeah that's a question
the question was around well un to
reform the UN because corporations and
states have too much have too much power
relative to citizens and people I think
one of the things that we've noticed in
recent years is a emergence of robust
civil society in individual countries
and the network of civil societies that
work together to maintain pressure on
governments on other centers of power
and to ensure that people do have
obviously I think the question of a
relationship between corporations and
governments is something that each
individual country is dealing with and I
know perhaps that's the question is much
more relevant today in Europe than it
would have been 34 years ago I've had
the chance to talk to people ordinary
people some who have lost their jobs and
the sense is that M corporations have
lots of our governments listen to them
and pay attention to their needs and
ignore the needs of the ordinary people
because they attitude is if I were not
able to pay for school fees the
government or the City Council term we
can't help you if I can't do certain
than they said we can't help you we have
no budget and suddenly with the crisis
that the same governments find found
billions to save bangs and to help other
institutions you cannot tell the
ordinary people that
is different it's important for the
credit to continue flowing and creditors
like blood in the system and therefore
one how to make sure these institutions
did not collapse and of course the
logical ones would ask you if you say is
too big to fail is it also too big to
succeed and this sense of abandonment by
the government makes these questions
type of questions even more important
they attitude as the big boys look after
themselves but I I think the best way to
tackle is for each government to have
the right regulatory system to ensure
that what has happened doesn't happen
and there are discussions about reforms
which I unfortunately has slowed as
economics begin to improve but reforms
are necessary and I think the banks and
the corporations should support these
reforms not not fight it as some appear
to be doing but I think at the end of
the day power still rest with the voters
and the people and if the voters and the
people of an issue which is important
they should push it up the political
agenda and the government and the
parliaments would take the right action
okay there's a question right there
thank you good afternoon and I'm very
pleased to be here my name is anchored
on above and I have a question for you
mr. Annan in Ronda happened to some
extent if I know correctly because of
mogadishu because President Clinton
didn't want another episode of Mogadishu
we had then Darfur and then we are now
having Syria it seems to me mr. on Honda
the world does not learn his lessons so
my question is what kind of reforms do
you see necessary to the UN system to
help this world learn its lessons or
getting better at it thinking you raised
a question of the un-led in his lessons
the UN is also the Member States and I
think you started your question rightly
by saying that he started in somalia
rwanda Darfur and that President Clinton
didn't want to take any risk in fact not
only did they not want to take risk they
came up with the law PDD 25 saying that
the US troops will not take part in UN
peacekeeping operations and if a country
as powerful as the u.s. is holding back
because it doesn't want to take risks
you can imagine the attitude of other
countries from Denmark to others going
to take risk in a situation where a
powerful us is afraid to go so then you
have a situation where the response is
either Mick or absent and in some
situations unfortunately the
international system puts in responses
which we know are not adequate you
mentioned there for there for the
initial approach was to get the African
Union to put in the trips and we knew
they didn't have a cup
30 I myself organized a pleasant
conference to support that force in
Addis we had very important countries
around the table from the u.s. to the
European countries China was there not
almost everyone promise to offer often
every one of it strategic airlift
strategic airlift means we will fly the
soldiers to Darfur that's the easiest
part that's the easiest part and
demonstrative are what is important is
to sustain them day in and day out for
5-10 years to make sure they have
equipment they are supplied they have
mobility they have helicopters nobody
would offer them so in the end to make
sure the operation didn't collapse
completely I came with I came up with an
idea of what we call the hybrid force
that the UN forces would team up for the
African forces and the UN will pick up
the tab that was the only way we could
sustain the operation to help this
Sudanese and so I think what we the
lesson that we need is for the member
states to understand that peacekeeping
is not a risk-free operation and for
them to explain to their population that
it will entail risk and we are prepared
to take it for the sake of humanity you
would notice when it's a peacekeeping
operation the government's don't want to
take any risks if it's a national
deployment us took thousands of
casualties in Iraq they took thousands
in some in Afghanistan in Somalia 16
soldiers were killed and they were out
if we approach peacekeeping an event a
collaborative effort this way we will
never be able to really do what you're
suggesting we do and I recall when the
US troops were pulled out I
in the head I was in the peacekeeping
department and I said the way the US
troops have pulled out is created the
impression that the easiest way to
disrupt a peacekeeping operation is to
kill a few peacekeepers and everybody
leaves and when this happened in what
when this happened in Rwanda and 10
Belgian soldiers were killed and the
Belgian troops were withdrawn and
somebody asked everyone these soldier
why did you do this he said we also
watched CNN was there was the answer
just just a quick vote on this we do you
think you know in many respects on
following on this question that Rwanda
paid the price for Somalia is Syria
paying the price for Iraq do you think
the world would have reacted differently
had we not gone through the experience
of the Iraq war yeah i think a
definitely rwanda paid the price for
somalia it was under the shadow of
somalia and here in Middle East in Syria
there are two issues we have the
experience in Iraq which is just next
door which has never been stabilized
even today they're bombings even today
there are bombings and then we have
Libya which also came just before Syria
where the Russians and the Chinese
believe that they had been deceived that
this did not veto a resolution to send
in their resolution to help the people
of Syria people of Libya to help the
people of Libya and that they were
deceived in the sense that they felt
that resolution was 10 very quickly into
regime change and Gaddafi was removed I
mean I'm not holding any brief for
Gaddafi but I'm telling you this was the
attitude and this ad was complicated the
relationship with them of Assyria even
when I raised a question of arms embargo
for Syria they said this is another
Libya
beginning of Libya so you had Libya you
have Iraq which has really complicated
the situation in Syria and also you have
an American president whose agenda for
the moment seems to be quite domestic
and also sees himself as a president who
is bringing the boys home and it was end
Wars and is now going to take on on
another war whether the European nations
were step in and fill the void I do not
know but I must say in in Lebanon in
2006 where we had to put troops in
southern Lebanon the Europeans provided
the bat born or the force and they
really stepped up to the plate the US
was not welcome but Europe did it okay
right in the middle there yes I think
you need to Mike give a microphone
there's a microphone coming away he said
no prayer saying I said he can speak up
thank you and what do you consider your
greatest personal failure as the
secretary-general of the UN greatest
personal failure no I think one of the
my biggest disappointment I think we've
touched on it was our inability to stop
the war in Iraq which I was really
opposed to with every vein in mind what
do you think believe in knowing or feel
it was absolutely wrong and I put in
lots of effort lots of phone calls lots
of fair discussions and really felt it
was something we had to avoid and we
failed I really took it as almost a body
blow it was a very painful experience we
see the results is a sort of situation
where people say you were right you
don't want to be right I wish we had not
broken it now we've broken it and we
can't really put it together at the
cider
I wonder what can be done in the UN
system especially in the Security
Council to assure that people speak the
truth what I'm thinking about is that
you remember everybody remember that we
saw Colin Powell before the ark war
speaking in the Security Council about
the weapons of Iraq nuclear weapons
biological weapons mass destructions
nasty drugs weapons and about the
connection to al-qaeda we wondered is
this is truth now we know this was not
true well in the court you have to tell
the truth you should wonder allergic I
think we have react when you can you do
something to to make sure the people
there tell the truth let me react to
your question I think that was one of
the tragic events in the sense that the
assistance of weapons of mass
destruction was the basis for the war
but let me say that yes Colin Powell
made a powerful presentation to the
Security Council but that presentation
did not convince a security council to
vote for the war the Security Council
did not authorize a war and in fact if
they had been a vote from my own private
count the u.s. probably would have got
four votes out of the 15 and so the
Security Council added people outside
the council may have taken a different
view but the council analyzed the
situation and
came to the judgment that we cannot
support this war and if any effect the
council and the system worked the way he
should have the fact that the US and its
allies went outside the council and took
action that I had described as illegal
and illegitimate he says something else
and they are the ones who have to answer
for the actions and I think history is
going to judge the say iraq war very
harshly this is also complicated for you
by personal relationships so we
described in the book how colin powell
came to you after the u.s. found the
mobile labs and he came in and he said
Kofi they've made an honest man of me
and what he meant by that is we finally
found the evidence evidence which of
course turned out not to be headed
either case but in the case of someone
like him do you think how do you explain
because he seems to a lot of people to
have been someone caught in a very
difficult situation what how would you
characterize his role was he being a
good soldier was he being was he
deceiving himself what is how would you
I think one has to look at the US
political system in the American system
American political system it is very
rare that people resign the only
resignation that people my generation
can remember on issues of principle in
American politics was a Saturday night
Massacre whence I bandstand a group of
them resigned otherwise it's a very rare
phenomena in fact some people put it
down to the power or the military
industrial complex that is so powerful
that you're going to need them and so
you don't quit and you don't resign an
issue of principle where they see was
unreliable person and nobody else will
take you in but so what you're saying is
in another system call empowered
resigned well let me let me go and on
top of that
Colin Powell is also a general in a
soldier and soldiers play by team and
mission and you stick together I say us
a team whether the possibility of
resignation cross his mind or not I
don't know but he are pressing a system
where you don't resign maybe in another
system I may have dinner let's see there
the gentleman right there yeah we have
some few hands in the front to see mr.
Annan thank you for coming to Copenhagen
today and for sharing your thoughts with
us in this book could you tell us based
on your experience as a secretary
general and based on the challenges at
the world is facing today what is a
major skill or the most important skill
at a secretary general should have thank
you he's my friend you know no I I think
the secretary Jenna at all times should
be open he should have an open mind he
should listen he should have a good team
around him he should have a good
judgment he should have a sense of humor
internally and externally including
sometimes laughing at himself and above
all he has to have that empathy and
compassion for his fellow man and woman
and bear their interest in mind but he
should also have ability to convince to
persuade all this and particularly the
big countries to do the right and auto
cab any excesses they may be inclined to
let me add to this since I can be a
little less modest and than you are I
think one of the things that I saw this
in a very first trip I took with you
which was actually to Denmark in 1997
and what I saw was a prime minister who
met you who had not met you before who
didn't know you and what I saw and I
think this is when I'm asked about mr.
Annan's leadership I think this is a
lesson that I certainly took away from
and looking at other leaders is your
ability to convince others that your
success was in their interest and that
made a huge difference and it was a big
contrast with your predecessor I can say
that but it made a very big difference I
think to your success was there a
question in the front here yes please I
would like to know do you think that
normal or traditional warfare is the
best way of fighting terrorism can you
put it happen yes do you think that a
traditional warfare it's the best way of
fighting terrorism and do you consider
their mark and winner we've we have the
last troops in there in Afghanistan now
they are going back and we will consider
as a winner well that's say yeah the
fight against terrorism has raised many
issues it has raised issues about
trade-off between civil liberty and the
fight against terrorism some governments
use the T word almost as alliances to do
whatever they want
and that is wrong and sometimes they
almost demanded their people to
understand that in the fight against
terrorism civil liberties and human
rights may be trampled upon but that's
okay trust me we are protecting you I
don't believe in that when you are asked
to give up your civil liberties and your
human rights for protection and you do
do you in the end have protection when
your rights are on the line I mean there
are lots of things happening today and
what they've because the program we came
up with the UN about fighting terrorism
focus more on governments working
together sharing intelligence not
providing haven for the terrorists going
after them with intelligence and picking
them up and maybe we did this because we
have no army but fighting terrorism with
a traditional warfare nami you have lots
of collateral damage lots of innocent
people get killed and of course talking
about this I'm now also beginning to get
and what very worried about the new
warfare using drones I mean today the US
has monopoly over drones other countries
are going to develop their own drones
and perhaps even better ones what are
the rules can anyone take to the air and
kill somebody in the country that they
are not at war with what sort of world
are we creating what should be the rules
and on this whole idea of targeted
assassination who are you killed
somebody because you suspect he or she
was going to do this on that or maybe
planning when the person is dead has no
possibility of answering know what what
is what sort of system are we witness so
we need to think very seriously
about all these sins before it becomes
free for all and other people develop
drones and we start going after each
other in in all sorts of rare places
which is part of the answer to your
question of using military means to
fight terrorism where they are
concentrated given for example take
Molly where they came in from Libya
tried to take Molly and then went into
and northern hideout and they are
concentrated and is say almost a state
of war that is different but the way is
going we can hit people in countries
which are not at war and in fact
sometimes we may not even admit we did
it okay time time time for a couple more
quick questions let's take right here in
the middle here if you just wait for the
microphone thank you um I would like to
know who do you consider the biggest
player when it comes to change in a
country where the government is
oppressing its people is it the
International Society with the UN member
states or is it the people of the
country and can they do without each
other I have no doubt in saying that is
the people of the country but sometimes
they need to be encouraged they need to
be supported and the international
system and people outside the country
can help you no sir it's almost like a
schoolyard then when you see somebody
bullying a group of children and others
a third party saying stop this can go on
you know can have incredible impact so
outside is saying you are right to be
fighting for your freedom to fight for
democracy but the outsiders cannot come
and impose it it has to come from the
people
and we often be sometimes make mistakes
thinking Outsiders can bring it in they
can't it has to be the people and they
need to be supported and strengthened to
do it but one of the things that's
interesting about this age is that you
see how technology is changing this
dynamic and you can see in countries
that are repressed outside providers can
provide technology that allows people to
organize and demonstrate without being
caught by the government and so then
private players can play more of a role
to ya know they can't have but then you
have another problem in this let's take
the Arab Spring the RF spring they use
in the Internet as a tool to organize
themselves to come out and do this and
people call it in internet revolution
but really the internet was a tool and
it the weaknesses ice also shown that
real leadership cohesive leadership was
missing the strength of the Arab Spring
was that it was a little revolution as
the weakness is that it's a little as a
duelist revolution and you have a is and
when you have that sort of fluid
situation is always they organized who
emerges on top and here the most the
best organized was a Muslim brothers and
they came up on top but they also knew
to government they've never governed
before and the taking of a whole country
and they are struggling and yet they
cannot touch some experienced people who
work with the old government because he
attainted so everybody is floating and
the economic and social situation in
Egypt is very difficult Taurus are not
going companies are downsides now
relocated or closing down and police
have not been able to set themselves and
it's a very difficult situation and the
Chinese one in 89 on the other hand was
what I call a faxed resolution
because the tool then was a fax the
student were sending faxes to each other
I was listening to report on BBC but the
best reports we got was to us where to
and UN staff members who had apartments
in Beijing overlooking the cinnamon
square and they were sending fax telling
us what was happening you know so they
the tools will give you the information
but you need the leadership and the
judgment to mobilize it and move forward
okay we don't say one more question and
the lady right here this fella when you
look back at your career and your
experience what advice would you give to
yourself as a young coffee on on I say
young curvy end yes go for it
you